[Música]
porque hoy 24 de marzo se cumple un mes
desde que estalló la guerra en ucrania
rusa russia atacó a ucrania el pasado 24
de febrero alegando que el gobierno
ucraniano era responsable de un supuesto
genocidio contra la población
rusohablante el donbass y con el
propósito de desmilitarizar y de
clasificar según las palabras de
vladimir putin más de 3.6 millones de
personas han huido de esta guerra según
la agencia para los refugiados de
naciones unidas mientras que con cada
día que pasa empeora la situación
humanitaria el sufrimiento se agrava en
la ciudad asediada deje en ruinas como
mariupol donde la gente lucha por
sobrevivir en medio de una fuerte
escasez de comida agua electricidad o
calefacción la vía diplomática continúa
sin grandes avances y rusia continúa
exigiendo la neutralidad de ucrania es
decir impedir que este país se adhiera a
la otan hay países occidentales con eeuu
quienes temen que rusia lance una
escalada militar con armas químicas o
ataques contra los convoys occidentales
de ayuda militar humanitaria el
presidente estadounidense joe biden se
encuentra en este momento en bruselas
para reunirse con un aliado clave con
sus aliados un esfuerzo por detener que
este conflicto escale y se espera nuevas
sanciones a rusia a coordinar más
asistencia militar para ucrania también
esfuerzos de largo plazo para impulsar
las defensas en europa del este y
reducir la dependencia del continente
del gas y petróleo ruso para ello
entonces quiero saludar a mi primer
invitado el es andrés servín pont
analista internacional y director de la
coordinadora regional de investigaciones
económicas y sociales gracias a android
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 por supuesto
empecemos por el balance que nos puede
dar de este mes que se cumple hoy de
esta invasión rusa
bueno muchas gracias por la invitación
la verdad que es difícil es un desafío
poder tratar de resumir lo que ha pasado
en un mes quizás algún pequeño estado de
situación sobre lo que está pasando en
el terreno estos últimos días hemos
visto como parece haberse por el
relanzado sino frenado parte de la
ofensiva rusa está teniendo dificultades
logísticas los ucranianos vienen
realizando contraofensiva y cada vez
parece de que la línea de la primera
línea de este conflicto en las
diferentes frentes que hay parece ir
fijándose y creando un conflicto un poco
más estático con algunas acciones de
lado y lado tratando de fortalecer sus
posiciones a medida de que avanzan y
también se frustran las diferentes
distancias de negociación
ahora vamos a hablar por favor de los
civiles los que sufren de primera línea
esta guerra cruenta no destructora hemos
visto sobre todo la ciudad de mariupol
la gente no tiene que comer que deber
calefacción no hay corredores
humanitarios para poder salir de esta
ciudad cuál es el balance de los civiles
que se puede dar que puede pasar cuantos
más refugiados
se estima que hay un cuarto una cuarta
parte de la población lo creerá se ha
quedado sin hogar la situación en varios
de estos centros urbanos es
absolutamente crítica marie paule es la
que toma se llega de buena parte de la
atención porque ha sido estudiada desde
el primer día las condiciones bajo las
que están viviendo los ciudadanos de
marie paule son completamente
catastróficas
y rusia apuesta a estas condiciones en
las ciudades que está asediando buscando
de que estas poblaciones capitulen lo
que fuerzan a sus autoridades a
capitular y entreguen la ciudad no varió
cual tiene un valor estratégico muy
importante para rusia por eso está serio
desde el principio pero no es la otra la
única digamos son estamos viendo por
ejemplo externa sirve en el norte está
empezando a parecer mucho mar y paul un
asedio contra la ciudad un bombardeo
brutal por parte de las fuerzas rusas en
un intento de tomar esta ciudad y lo
veremos también en otras como lo hemos
visto en karting como lo hemos visto en
mi cali son varias las que están
sufriendo este tipo de asedios de
acciones contundentes por parte del
instrumento militar ruso y estas
acciones no se consideran crímenes de
guerra crímenes de lesa humanidad por
atentar a la población civil
indiscriminadamente
y es que efectivamente estamos viendo
que rusia ya dejó atrás esta etapa que
vimos en los primeros días del conflicto
en el cual trató de enfocarse en empleo
de armamento de precisión para ataques
quirúrgicos y neutralizar ciertas
capacidades militares hoy en día la
regla es volver al empleo tradicional de
la artillería como siempre hizo rusa en
este tipo de operaciones es un empleo
masivo e indiscriminado que no tiene
ninguna consideración a que se esté
usando en espacios con alta densidad
demográfica espacios urbanos y esto es
lo que está generando la enorme
destrucción que vemos en las imágenes
que salen de mariupol y de otras
ciudades
la cantidad de bajas civiles que se está
dando y también que los corredores
humanitarios muchas veces saturados y
que a la vez también se convierten
muchas veces en objetivos por parte de
las fuerzas rusas la situación realmente
en términos humanitarios es desastrosa
pero sin embargo continúan los diálogos
andrei porque que buscan estas partes de
alegando cuando en verdad han tenido ya
más de cuatro rondas y no han tenido
ningún tipo de avance
bueno rusia necesita encontrar algún
tipo de victoria no necesita putin en
particular quiere tener algún tipo de
victoria su victoria original era poder
hacer el capitular o que se rinda el
gobierno de ese link que en los primeros
días del conflicto eso claramente no era
militarmente ex factible lo cual ahora
reduce sus opciones sobre que puede
presentar como una victoria y por otro
lado crean está sobre está peleando por
su propia supervivencia entonces las
condiciones que tienen ambos para poder
percibir la victoria son muy altas y no
son compatibles acá en algún momento o
sea las negociaciones van a avanzar
cuando son ambos ambas partes que estén
dispuestas a perder que va a ser el
resultado final de una negociación
también hablemos de las sanciones
importantes paquetes de sanciones por
parte de la comunidad internacional
occidental hablamos de eeuu también de
la unión europea han tenido realmente
impacto porque digamos que el presidente
vladimir putin de todas formas sigue su
ofensiva parece que estas sanciones no
le y no les importa mucho qué es lo que
realmente está pasando con estas
sanciones
portarán de verdad vladimir putin es una
fachada para decir no pasa nada igual yo
sigo con combinación no me bajar a
amedrentar por estas sanciones pero a un
mediano plazo efectivamente van a tener
un efecto una población
y las sanciones yo creo que en una
instancia inicial se imaginaba que iba a
haber una fuerte presión económica y
diplomática sobre el país probablemente
nuestras dimensiones pero putin está
mostrando ninguna voluntad de echarse
para atrás entonces sigue subiendo la
apuesta el efecto también al mediano y
largo plazo que esto puede tener y esto
es lo que preocupa a muchos analistas es
en este tipo de presión lo que no está
haciendo es empujar a rusia en los
brazos de china no claro y que esto
genere condiciones ideales para que
china
defina los parámetros bajo los cuales
quiere fortalecer sus sociedades
estratégicas con rusia entonces el día
de mañana vamos a estar viendo con una
relación china rusia mucho más
consolidada que afecten los intereses
negativamente en los países de occidente
en particular de los miembros lo tal
puede ser